[Music]  Surf's Up for Kim Kardashian just a  little slice of heaven the Keeping Up  with the Kardashians star's spent her  4th of July in the great outdoors trying  her hand at wakeboarding she wasn't  necessarily a natural but after a few  tries Kim was up surfing the waves  the 37 year old reality star shared  several videos of herself on the water  via insta story plus this shot of her  posing it up in a patriotic and navy  blue printed bikini and wakeboarding  wasn't the only water sport Kim  participated in okay which should go on  the water side first in the trampoline  the mom of three also featured her  adorable kiddos on her story check out  this cute clip of two-year-old seat  loving up on his baby sister Chicago it  seems little CT couldn't get enough of  shy and what holiday is complete without  s'mores and a brisk hike  [Music]  [Applause]